question if men do would you agree men
do value fertility
[Music]
like in general men prefer younger women
yeah yeah
so what age do you think it's over
when when would you qualify women as
leftover because at some point like the
guys aren't lining up for girls at 75
right so so at some point it ends right
where where would you pinpoint that
and I'm curious for you you why don't
you guys all give your answers so when
you start
okay
okay first of all
um you know oh to be 21.
but at 21 by the time you reach 35
what have you been doing like say 20. we
start our relationships what did we say
speaking to the mic I'm sorry brother
why did I have to be the first to do
that but yeah so you start your
relationships from like 16 16 to 35.
all them years what have you been doing
you've had that you've had Downs
going back to what you say by then
there's issues there's trauma there's
you know your your
you've been through a lot you've got
certain guards up because you've been
hurt in certain ways you're seeing
similar traits in partners that you saw
in somebody else that's why when I say
at 35
if I if I see you at 35 I'll be able to
recognize okay this has happened to you
that's happened to you you've put this
time frame on that I don't want to do
this until then and at 35 what's that
geriatric pregnancy so it's high risk
high-risk pregnancy so
for men we have babies until the end of
time for you
from 35 it gets risky it does
so you can say ah you know
if I'm single today which I'm not
but if I was
I'm I I've got a goal down the spectrum
because I don't want that risk why am I
gonna have a risk of your 35 you're
gonna have certain baggage because we
all got baggage so but
you know by then it's other people's
stuff that's coming into my relationship
and guess what I don't want it so by 35
you need to be
more or less
in your stride with someone even if it's
not marriage even if it's not marriage
you shouldn't be on the market at 35.
so I'm not saying you have to be married
but I'm saying you need to be clearly
off the market
but what do you think
um so
um
I'm not too sure like
I wouldn't class people being that's
over 35 as a leftovers that's I feel
like that's a bit of a kind of
a real time but um
I feel like regardless regardless of the
age you're still gonna have like you're
still gonna go through [ __ ] like in life
you're always going to go free stuff me
personally I would like for me to be
like in a stable relationship which I
don't feel like I'm ready for right now
I'd want to be like
stable in myself like mentally like and
before I bring that to someone else
because like if I'm in a relationship
with someone and it's now becoming a and
I come with all my bag is that's going
to cause issues in a relationship if I'm
not secure
um in terms of
the age I would consider
I don't know I don't really know because
then like like you said people that are
like 70 plus years old no one's really
you I mean very few probably but like
I don't know and then at the same time
as well you we did say like looks kind
of you start with look yeah yeah there's
people that are 35 that don't look safer
there is that so once I know okay just
one quick question have you you've been
in a relationship before yeah yeah
and it's affected you
no I'm not saying negative or positive
I'm just saying this affected you it's
changed the course of why you've decided
I'm just finding me I'm doing this so 15
years of that
I find you in 15 years time have gone
through that
all right let's say three or four times
that's nobody really wants what you're
gonna come with because you would have
done it many times
and you haven't figured it out
you haven't self-diagnosed yourself and
found out what what you need to do so
that's why I say at 35 it's different
when you're young you know but if you
keep and I'm not I'm not saying this to
you whether it's having a conversation
but um just in general if you keep doing
the same thing and getting the same
outcome by the time
we meet I'm 40 you're 35 I'll be like
there's this just like bad luck
four times and I'm saying four times
because I'm being respectful I'm saying
four times because I'm being respectful
yeah can I just say that
you're saying about 35. but if you're
young wouldn't it be easier to be in a
stable relationship get married when
you're young when you haven't got that
trauma yes you haven't got that
experience so as far as I'm concerned
the Younger You Can Get Married the
better because you're saying like oh
you've got you've got to do this you
might have to do traveling you might
have to do this you have to do that you
have to do this and do that by the time
you're 35
who wants you you've done everything who
wants you you've got to think to
yourself you're looking at all these
stars but what have you got to offer a
man at 35 when you've been through
everything you've done everything you've
got all this history behind you've got
all this trauma wouldn't it be easier
while you're young to get your head
together and just say right but I'm
going to find someone same level as me
I'm going to get married the earlier the
better
no trauma both enjoy the experiences
together learn together grow together by
the time you're 35 you've done
everything and a man's gonna look at you
and think what am I doing with her when
I can go and get somebody younger
okay so I feel like I have a lot of
problems with a lot of things you said
one thing is you kind of made the
assumption that um
you don't have you won't you can't get
Trauma from a marriage like he said
one positive from marrying early is that
you don't have traumia you can have
Trauma from your childhood like I
wouldn't say that you should just equate
being young with not necessarily having
any problems having experienced life
um and another thing I would say is
again I feel like marriage is a huge
commitment that shouldn't be undermined
like once you've married someone you're
committed to them like what they want if
they wake up tomorrow and they decide
they want to move across the world that
impacts you and those kind of things
those Tendencies are more likely to
happen when you're young and you don't
really you're still trying to figure out
life
so I would agree I would disagree with
oh you should
aim to marry early so I have a question
do you think that what do you think is
more traumatizing one partner or what
would you say the average body count
well I was being generous yeah okay okay
so so let's say like by like 35 right
how many partners would that girl have
had over the years like what's more
traumatizing one or okay so this is
another problem you can't equate
someone's quality and who they are to
their body count like so so this is this
is a common misconception that a lot of
girls have and the reason you can is
because if a girl's a virgin on her
wedding night she has an 80 chance of a
happy marriage if she sleeps with five
or more guys it goes down to 25 percent